c'est pourquoi tu es là pas mal oui j'ai
une petite idée oui c'est pourquoi l'at
on arrive parce que juste un film à
montmagny de traître alors imagine sais
pas je me rends compte d'enjeux boîte de
nuit un soir c'était super comment tu me
le racontait et moi je te dis à tout le
moins des chapeaux la bomba latina
le pasteur avec le président hu est
et puis il ya thierry frémont dans le
monde constituent des biens sociaux
autrement pas mal du tout et ça m'a vite
et c'est une histoire qu'on n'a jamais
traité sino malienne l'espace en 1944
dans l'épuration autant il a eu des
films saw wire ou métal en opération les
créations des collabos c'est l'époque on
trouvait les femmes et ne s'était pas
traduit attendu en film non parce que
j'ai pas travailler mais j'ai quelqu'un
qui a travaillé à s'en sortir car qui
veut se racheter ce sera acheté des
papiers d'identité une bonne conscience
un futur quoi donc je suis une femme
amoureuse s'est sacrifié hier est en
fait bon c'est pour ça que je les fais
c'est pour ce n'est pas un premier gros
c'est rolls tu veux un second rôle très
intéressant parce que ça me permettait
de montrer mon côté tendre générés
je connais très bien avec le grand
public ne connaît pas obligatoire qui
sacrifie pour l'homme qu'elle aime ça
donc voilà ce que j'en dirai plus je
dois magie coiffer revanche d'accord
mais je vais devoir très bien sa fine
équipe comptant réalisateur josé
giovanni
y'a pas du solide en film oui à 10
heures
[Musique]
exemple réduit est ce que tu préfères
passé une nuit avec un mec que tu aime à
la folie et
ou une semaine avec un mec que tu aimes
moyennement c'est vraiment une question
super coureur quoi passer même une demie
nuit avec l'homme que j'aime évidemment
alors et si tu étais obligé je pars un
jour que j'ai faite prisonnière
ouais on te dit ouais c'est une idée
comme ça tout ça un jeu et ce à la
baisse et les questions cons alors j'ai
faite prisonnière à puis on te dit voilà
est obligé de faire l'amour avec la
personne avec qui on va enfermer dans
cette cellule voilà ce que la sûreté est
ce que tu préfères faire l'amour avec
une fille ou avec les vraiment qui vous
pousse à l'homosexualité alors je sais
pas moi et des gens qu'elle allait ouais
non c'est pas trop de temps passes tu
préfères la fille jamais essayé les
films et je crois que si j'étais obligé
je préfère encore et c'est définitif est
définitif au genre ce bordel à tsonga
j'ai pas encore sécurisée alors
maintenant question impossible à mon
sens
mais certaines personnes peuvent y
répondre est ce que tu préfères renault
ou goldman 2 3
je sais pas s'il ya un long silence là
tu arrives pas j'arrive pas à ma vie
j'en étais sûr mon avis c'est une
question à laquelle peugeot entend
répondre par oui non et global agir
local pour qui tu as le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à qui tu
trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux mecs qui se tape des petites
filles elles font ça pour l'argent ou
alors un jeune mec qui toujours pour
l'argent tapent sur des vieilles
vraiment pas dire qu'on soit bien
compris la question oui oui maintenant
j'essaie d'imaginer tableau est bien
celle d'un pardon le plus sinon je te
demande pas de tout mettre
oui je pardonne aux jeunes je suis part
de nos jeunes qui tapent sur des
vieilles ouais parce que son pc c'est
qu'il est obligé de s'en sortir à bon il
est un bon d'accord alors que l'autre il
est pas obligé de payer des petites
filles laurent l'autre c'est un pervers
si tu rentres chez toi soir avec un
garde son discours prévu qu rentrer avec
lui c'est pas ton fiancé habituel etc
c'est un garçon tu as rencontré genre la
première question coup de foudre
et puis tu as oublié quelque chose sur
la table de nuit
un objet assez compromettants sur ma
table de nuit ou et avant lui il manque
six mois oui tu le ramène chez toi femme
vient chez toi en janvier corps a été
oublié qu'est ce qui te gêne le plus
d'avoir oublié mind chaos ou un
godemiché
ah c'est terrible y a rien sur ma table
de nuit et par rapport au delà vraiment
mais ce qui me gêne le plus vis-à-vis du
avec ce mec tu as envie de te montrer
vis-à-vis de lui si tu veux tu veux
montrer que tu es une fille bien et tout
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui te gêne le plus
de winne moi je crois que ces mannequins
tenez bon deuxièmement site était amputé
d'un membre
c'est tragique
on va être obligé de vous amputé d'un
membre on est obligé toi c'est un jeu
alors l'euskal un bras ou une jambe un
bras dans lequel le bras droit le bras
gauche de gauche évidemment très
droitière et site était maître du monde
tu ferais quoi demain matin entre
éveillant puis devient maître du monde
fermé 13 du monde ça coince habilité et
nerveux que jamais maître du monde et la
première chose que tu fais
ce serait aider les gens mais je sais
pas comment site maîtres du monde peut
faire plaindre mais ted qui en première
j'ai dû tout l'argent qui est un
prisonnier politique déjà dans tous les
pays
ouais dans tous les pays déjà il ya du
boulot avec beaucoup de boulot et puis
ensuite je taxe jeu texte toutes les
denrées alimentaires stockées en surgelé
web monde entier ils envoient dans les
pays sous alimentés
parce qu'il ya des aliments stockées en
surgelé concert pas tout simplement
parce que veut pas que les prix baissent
pas d'alimentation et ça ça me met hors
de moi alors qu'on envoie des cartons de
protéines
c'est une si belle alors donc les
maîtres du monde peut tout changer
ou est-ce que tu mettrais la france sur
la carte du monde tu pouvais choisir
tout d'assurer je vais amel actifs
je suis la maîtresse à se réunissent
dans l'océan mais aussi sympathique soit
une grande polynésie coin grand palais
paris nice et paris tu le mets très haut
par rapport à ça mais à paris bien si tu
es seul tu vas mettrait pas à cannes par
hasard
non non non je te parlais d'un style
dernière question kong
je te dis la bombe arrive dans cinq
minutes la bombe atomique
ouais elle va tomber sur paris qu'ils
ont sur la concorde
qu'est ce que tu fais dans les cinq
dernières minutes je vais te dire je
sais pas etc ou petit confiance et la
proximité je ne jette dans ses bras
toute seule ici c'est là nous on a dû
polémique comme mais je crois qu'un
maquillage et les premiers concernés
mais je crois que c'est dans un moment
pareil en a besoin surtout de ce
sentiment va se sentir seul point contre
lui l'a tant que ça pour quoi
ce n'est pas une prière par hasard non
pour le dollar
ouais
sparrow gens peuvent aller au ciel or je
sais pas du tout où est ce qu'on va
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux